presidential candidate Michael Bloomberg
is worth a reported 64 billion dollars
his opponent Bernie Sanders a
millionaire and self-proclaimed
socialist calls that wealth grotesque
and immoral visit in 2018 Bloomberg LP
cleared a two billion dollar profit on
ten billion in revenue so eight billion
mostly went to pay the companies
nineteen thousand employees by squeezing
billionaires we risk reducing innovation
and harming workers building and
managing a large business can be
virtuous and comes with personal rewards
and costs work becomes life replacing
hobbies family and relationships the
real-life scandals on page six show that
money can work personalities and wreak
human happiness money is important and
makes our lives easier but if we could
see the sacrifices behind the fortunes
would we still be envious Adam Smith
likened large fortunes to a curse
wealthy business owners think they're
working for themselves he said but the
payoff mostly winds up in the pockets of
people that never even met
does money buy happiness or does it come
from somewhere else let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and check the link in the
description below for my new piece on
Sanders Bloomberg and Adam Smith